start streaming rapping they're talking
yes let's get this rolling tweet Pavan I
see YouTube is listening is saying
things I like to see what stream health
alright YouTube looks good and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
and the Lords are gaming dotnet episode
number 129 it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
Lord's Day and we've got halos infinite
future Paul J does it yeah you're
literally the minute I said that he's
like yeah release details Sony EU
layoffs coalition banning gears 5
players and stadia negative latency to
discuss so we could get right into it
yes Jade um we know why you are here
school talking a building was good over
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original laws of realm here
at the round table my coals with the
cold notes my brother from another
mother the difficult game Conqueror Lord
of reviews and the house of the young
wolf mommy Lord Adonai Glazer I'm going
crazy over destiny twos raid shout out
to all the people who act like they know
what they talking about on lfd but
really you don't look there if only
thing you watch is the cactus HD video
and then that makes you believe that you
know what's going on why don't you not
go on lfg go to the beginners only and
go there yo i'ma need you to get a super
Chester from ya get the super chair will
be that I know what rap you might be
onto something
breath breath breath on God in them they
need to drop you will bet your knees on
that button
we doing means of resources because rap
where we gonna have you on camera you
can unbox your knees we might have to
get bribe in here and do a do a I've
been the knee segment number he gonna
ban the hell out of me if you keep
around with that no you do kept in
flip-flops
I put the slippers back so what else
been just frustrated with people in the
rain just not listening yeah I feel like
people have a very strong sense that I
didn't do nothing wrong it's your fault
and makes me want to come through the
mic and just strangle people food but
you know I I'm a peaceful individual so
I'm not gonna strangle anyone but you
know I might I don't know yet let's keep
going picked up Zelda's awakening yeah
I'll talk more about that next week oh
yeah I only got like 30 minutes in it
like I can't really put a whole lot of
validation on my opinion on an old down
Odin literally just got my sword - got
into a forest and pretty much out of
closes you think you play the old
already don't know mm-hmm these two is
too young for that were you talking
about condom showing up all of a sudden
on 11 I see y'all man we love that like
to see though our regular faces at your
table that's what's up
and of course we had our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gay mole is for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mr. offline
profile Illuminati and lore patron of
the iron baked mommy
Lord sovereign I do it give morning
gentlemen you'd a new art the Fleck
you're just making up your own reality
in Kings back in the goalposts all of a
sudden now the back never had anything
to do with certain games being back some
games none let us remember let us
remember that the bet was there's gonna
be back you're not you're ready before
you're gonna pay for us are you going to
pay for days already own yes you will
pay for stuff you own how what you just
said have anything to do with what you
were talking about on Twitter all week
oh nothing the only thing I was gonna
say is we do what we get to the
PlayStation 5 discussion there is a new
report and we'll revisit the knees
between you two
being that you are so heavily invested I
want you to mail-order yummies over this
way please super shower is he over with
dizzy izzy is our brother
hope you're doing better my brother pay
up King you're gonna have heavy knees in
the box
yeah more than one that means his more
than one knees in the box the box is
heavy know about us we have a thing with
the box right we used to yeah if you in
the box you or not you do not want to be
in man I planted in his weekend a little
bit of Zelda over dowas even get a
chance Plato beer will we play too much
when you worry I'm like I'm like Sony
Microsoft I don't comment on speculation
surrounding school on the school just
I'll get you something big today I don't
know I told you I buy you check out oh
yeah
Magnusson Weezer the seasonal opulence
the new silly appellees jump-off
young can whoever had the whole little
camera
I got ya know positioning with Jamie
looked like he talked him from out of
the black hole cause by choosing a black
hole in the back we can't eat it we had
no choice cinema from the front like
every is situated it's just that
particular data is something I like the
typical I people would get busy so we
are do you know on the fly but that out
man roundtable review as the large III
needs yeowwww I think you understand
what grab damn thank you so much hundred
dollar super chair you can have seen
before
and it was from him and say I'm sorry
and nothing I want you to come on and
get at it because right now sovereigns
is buckling and buckling and we how's it
going over that happen long Cassidy one
that's what he asked to shot the Lord
well my lady said sorry missed you guys
last week always enjoy the show we
always love doing it we always love
having a good time
never apologize for missing mail just
the fact that you here really means a
lot in the super chat wow I don't even
know what to say about that that is just
truly humbling
um abdominus Maximus okay so question
how how does Bratz figure into this
whole thing what did Brad say because
you know I don't pay attention to
Twitter's okay Oh George III
on football player on quarterback back
up a career backup quarterback that has
bad means they can't get on the field so
every time like he get hit his knees go
one way his body go another plate okay
so he came at me because how the door
says then I can't grab a fraud yes
did I call bribe a fraud and how does
brat figure into this he's trying to
John you know John Stockton situation no
I don't want to say it was you before
they started this you know and let me
tell you something you would never know
brats position because brat will talk
right so Brad got the flip-flop so you
same Brad got a flip-flop switch on one
day he stayed you know what it is you
don't even have different chairs he's
got like the back of its one listen
right now
grab his PC cuz you see that high-power
PC he got right now I think that PC got
ahold of him my xbox on Twitter - I'm
keeping my xbox how does that transpire
their breath aka the access game oh the
lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement Oh beloved Lord
care how you do example I'm kind of set
man yeah no better get to that website
and get it hold it at a one-to-one
minutes in the back she's looking
succulent people I'm gonna race bro I
know she don't look good as that actual
woman oh uh because the north I do it at
the end then you know I usually hit
y'all with the trial
they will monetize us and we will not be
listen
so unbox my links a weekend and I was
like oh first of all I'm gonna can't
wait for my asthma dog versus Diaz um I
really think that's gonna be must set it
off moment for the year for the UFC I
really think so
because I was looking at that right I
didn't know your man Maz Bergdorf was
down with Kimbo Slice and I'm back in a
day or work yes in the backyard back in
the day boy now with that backyard
boogie what he did was he took out Kimbo
Slice number one gonna mhm on a regular
come on like that they called him up and
he was like yo you come up so they show
him he had the man bun in his head mm-hm
so dudes was clowning him as he came up
with a man but now remember Kimbo Slice
do was a certified hitter in his soul
they use that deal to just knock off
people no guy for they can get to Kimbo
Slice like a gay cable yeah he was a gay
people my boy he proceeded to put hands
on Kimbo Slice gatekeeper mm-hmm Kimbo
Slice gatekeeper was throwing up in the
corner he was exhausted and couldn't I
go any further your are people in the
back to get it back up get up and Maz
but don't put them hands on them so I
really like the demeanor of this kid now
the fact that I really like me yes and
the smacking people in the face and the
level of disrespect the fact that he
Akana all choked out you got kudos from
me and kinda had to play that position
on a second fight with him you know this
is might this might be that that point
that turning point in a year for the UFC
this might be UFC fighting yet yeah
absolutely this is definitely the
gangster you don't
it definitely has that it can it can
definitely be that they better promote
this dude like no other if he beats Nate
Diaz they better promote this me like no
other mm-hmm also alright point I'm
playing Link's Awakening and unlike
addict I have an affinity for the game
because remember when you had your
Gameboy and you wanted Iselle the game
you didn't have one till that one writen
and it looked cute back then they took
the cuteness and put it on the screen
and look like a living god what I really
liked about it is like they have no
because to my understanding that was not
in this game at all from this they make
that aware like he wakes up he's like
he's like I don't know whose that is I'm
like good I want that chick in this game
anyways shoot lightning arrow lightning
hair light arrows myself I don't need
her doing nothin destiny okay alright so
my Florida read last week with destiny
in saying that you know the regurgitated
content mm-hmm
so now sitting down with a can
regurgitate Obama again and I'm shifting
through the pebbles I realize that is
the same regurgitating content that are
paid for before but it has a little
little little sauce to it they put some
jump some jewelry on it did yesterday
night I put them they put sunday shoes
bass on it okay and you know I really
love the nostalgic feeling when you go
into the Hellmouth and you see places
that she was at because I was talking to
Hollow is it and Mason hmm and I'm like
don't you remember this you do all of
that have you based the whole story yet
no it gets way worse why it's especially
when you're in that pyramid man that's
when stuff before you said what are you
going into kids
he's a dick Jim Jones bawling yeah but I
like the direction of it even though I'm
upset I see this is my problem I'm
sympathetic because I know what they did
what they was going through um I have
this mixed-up feeling with knowing that
they sold a soul to the devil right they
got they sold back these are this is the
only company got they're so bad and that
doesn't happen for most parts but what
about the perspective King like you know
I know what you say yes you know shot
the slow-mo if he was getting the whole
but he's giving my disco a fire he was
talking a whole bunch I got to be honest
with you what he said isn't false like
the thing is is like they're
regurgitating old constant but they're
doing it in a cool way
here's the thing not making excuses I
know sorry ass off grumbling OH the
question the big is also it's like
there's something to be said that if
then you got to realize we definitely
drink in the act like we got bias
towards that's the issue the issue comes
down to this though like I hear what
King is saying where he's on to
something in a sense that it's something
if someone else controls your masters
told your story right you don't have as
much input but now you get all your
masters back now you like you know what
let's take it back to the essence and do
it how we wanted to do it there's
something to be said about that that's
all I'm trying to say now question a
half you guys know right there already
indicated that they have they already
I'm assuming Jason Jones move has moved
on to try to figure out what the next
thing is and it's probably not destiny
three so what happens if for the rest of
the life of Destiny's - you just keep
getting weaker you hate the content and
you know I think day three is coming
I do you think the same routine with my
maybe not next year but the year after
that but I do think I just think I think
that they want to redefine to find out
how they truly want to do these seasons
friend because like when you launch d3
that's the best chance they're gonna
have to get back everyone want to make
sure they had all of their Domino's in a
row before they push that first one over
because once they push that first one
over you're only gonna have DLCs Theresa
to sell to people you're not gonna have
a full ganking you don't I don't think
so because right now then a perfect
space mmm
I dis pace it they in right now once
they launch the free-to-play right
mm-hmm
that's space right there kind of locks
him that was you that was usually the
boot lock in because now you can DLC
this to death it's not like the graphics
is bad the graphics is top-notch right
so where else would you want to go with
the graphics you don't want to go
anywhere else because the the characters
are ready it's it's not about that it's
about rebranding like look when you
start trying to sell DLC to someone or
you know this season passing they're
doing like people are just gonna see
that as as as just content being added
onto an old game right when you sell a
brand new game to people people look at
it more mmm their truck you know right
now their definitive thing is that we
need to get the destiny hardcore people
happy and we need to get them back in
the game look at it for me - I'm actual
question I have a reverb in the
background you're their own do you do
you think there ever be a fortnight to
add it to be honest probably not but
right know this is a difference this is
different this is a different scenario
than I did gaming for this a fortnight
went from a from a a paid expansion to a
battle royale this isn't a battle royale
okay this is what you're used to that
this is there might be a fortnight to
when they do next JIT next-gen consoles
like we don't know what a pic doing and
they could do whatever epic want to do
at this point I don't think it'll be a
fortnight - and I do not think it'll be
a destiny three one-step free-to-play
model is loose but it's not but it's not
really free to play doh and it says it's
just they look they let you land on a
planet actually do so when you gotta go
do something we already know how
checkout station anybody get to you
wanna play God of War you go ahead to
swipe the credit card stand what you're
saying I just feel that that I don't
really knows I don't see it I'm be
honest which I just really don't see it
I guess if it was but but haven't they
come openly and said that they're gonna
be a destiny 3 yeah they just look
they're not gonna let I'll be sure that
can maybe turn that to expansion's like
if this was if we was already in scarlet
and PS 5 and we're standing here now and
they have all this years before the next
gen I would say yeah there's probably
knuckle be a destiny 3 but they're gonna
try to sell next gen with something I
mean they're not good and they're not
good like you gotta consider when you go
into it's an extra gen like that's the
Refresh like right now destiny to as
much as we like it right now it still
got that tarnish on it that they did
from the beginning rush in we're not
like doing new people in with day no
matter how much you add to it you're not
bringing anybody knew it but put a 3 on
that and use like this is a brand new of
[ __ ] if you want to fight oryx's sister
listen that's right I flip flop my way
to a superior game experience went from
a penny shut up
PC master-race shout out the brat bag
the owning the trunk but he still gets
on here to play with other people shut
up when he did his unbox and he had his
PC and how he laid it out to everybody
to see if you haven't seen the video you
really need to go see Brad's video with
unboxing of his PC he is you know
very happy I love to see stuff like that
I love to see people joy I love to feel
like I'm part of their experience and he
brought that across really well and
playing destiny or playing stuff on PC
is a really different beast you know
and
completely different game on I try not
to hang out with y'all guys destiny is
such a different game on PC that I have
a PC that's broken down right now I'm
like man I can't wait to get back
different game on PC that it is the
leading platform for shy of the screen
we said even those bungees following the
fortnight model they changed something
week to week instead of having a big dlc
drop agreement we are going to move on
is we have bust out a density markers I
don't know where but anyway I got me
Laura kognito gaming Lord of the
cooperative experience spreading that
rumor sin Rhoda I'm ILP now tell me what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear so you already know it's been all
about going to salvation raid shout out
my boy
each party shut up my Boy Scout role now
who's on the last word got us through
man that it counted it's very messy it
is very hard um yeah these guys run a
real tight ship we was able to get
through a boy I need that real tight
ship man my ship has been sneaking over
and over like you know what I feel like
I feel like like that that ship that
just gets barbera on CDs and like you're
trying your hardest to stop this water
from coming in but it's just like sooner
or later you're gonna see you know it
but you stay on the ship anyway oh yeah
man it's you know it's rough but um you
know we got it done you know shoutout to
that and um also what else I'm trying to
think um been playing there all I want
to give a shout shout the more dizzy man
back on the mend
he's got given up for his a Red Dead I
mean all his are battle round two of his
battle with you know it was kind of
situation so we rock with him every step
and he just wanted to let us know to
shout out big bad John with the care
package that hooked him up with that
Borderlands 3 so shut salute to dizzy
salute the big bad John so that's what I
got but saw we got to get into some
business right yes sir man yes sir it's
it's that time a month once again
patreon time for us it's time for say to
say thank you to all of our wonderful
patrons who support the Lord every
single month you know we love you guys
we appreciate everything you guys do for
us a lot of this stuff could not be done
without your help so we greatly
appreciate it so let's go with these
rundowns
give
shoutouts and then we'll get into these
giveaways so of course our first patreon
is Lord Xavier Medina in your bags I'm
trying to solve out here giving it up
hanging out meds finally as they
chilling out with Lords over I do an R&R
with the Lord so what makes it look very
nice very nice people I should have been
there to hold the camera lord eat you
don't listen to him off forever patron
Lord Cory lytic aka Lord whisky you know
and of course followed by Lord slow-mo
backslap read the greatest avatar in the
business in the business coming up next
we have Lord HB 33 woo your support much
approval little brother salute and of
course followed by Lord Nintendo Direct
the low earth Thank You Nick much
appreciate it and we have next Lord
Wraith the Emperor the Emperor
ah not that again followed by Lord QX 7
masters thank you for your support
Zorro Thank You Lourdes or sorrow next
up we have Lord
I almost said I almost said they go they
go you go worry about the go [ __ ]
back 67 68 thank you sir let's throw
them outside I read these and witness
protection you by the Lord stitch 66 69
Thank You therapy brother ready for this
today boys next Lord vagabond Oh next up
we have we have a brother who's been
posting some very positive messages on
on Twitter this right here I mean as
always he's always been a positive dude
always just all about the games and the
fun in the community but any Forte oh
yes a lot of Forte he's got a meat
cleaver in them we have red rinchen
around or undead 3xb
I love you free agents we have Lord
lynchpin thank you sir ex cloud the wall
of ball feel girl you looking at Stadium
Scott for the salut salut semi press
guys Mike whoa somebody here somebody's
clap just went crazy
Oh
that's yeah we're judging okay next up
we have Lord Night Music
thank you sir for all the support much
appreciated next up we have the Lord of
the self-professed flip-flop man king of
BC elitist frat brother presence around
our first patron ever the man who's
usually first in the chat every single
week monkey punch himself Lord Michael
look what I did was right it's the loops
a loop Oh monkey punch no monkey paw we
have the Lord of the stream team and the
King at a ban hammers himself Lord snout
though I know he's having quite the time
erasing people from our from our gleam
giveaway
rajala a tree in a building yes sir
family from the cradle to the grave Lord
em bird himself Lord loaded pixels they
invert exactly okay next up we have Lord
CDF a slurp - cold
daddy I hope you have home watching
instead of driving around our chillin
I'll be making my cash
come on us on the road
someone who does arrest you got arrest
that's we change how you do it sir thank
you so much for the slow next up we have
Lord J Pereira 99 thank you sir for the
support
oh yeah wait right there Lord Jameson in
a building salute no doubt and of course
last but never least brother whom across
the pond Lord death singer himself or
death singer I would really a video to
play on xbox doesn't allow you listening
and adding has been hanging out tough
lately make a broken fill away I like
that check it out if you like what you
like though your legs that see you buddy
he's the stronger like I look we ain't
talking about that Betty said facts he
just say some random stuff really not
even talking about any more like you
know what else was amazing what we was
we was in a LMG and someone's like the
deathsinger know what he's doing I was
like man he's got an accent all accent
people right oh wow
this is hardcore it IOT yes sir so now
let's get into these giveaways I'm gonna
start out with oh oh
just $10 give away $10 card giveaway and
the winner of our $10 gift card giveaway
Lord Undead Oh
Oh Undead follow that we have the $20
gift card giveaway
I give Lee heaven to do it the $20 gift
card giveaway 21 to 20 no you get that
you get that shadow keep rape we don't
you love that River I gave the $10 to my
man and dead alright now our final
giveaway for the month of what we're
knocked over cheesy guys it's not
Klingon this gets flowing I'm by alright
III baby packs too fast anyway our
teespring giveaway goes to Lord J
Pereira 99 right gentlemen so I will
contact each and every one of you in
your DMS or email let you know what's
what that you guys tell me exactly what
you what what platform you want these
for but once again as always thank you
guys for your support much of this damn
near all of it cannot be done without
you guys you guys are amazing so thank
you said the Lord's I hear Breaking and
CAW violations iron bank is not privy to
any of this information thank you
listen there and we also trying to get
you all to join
um me and Eric was working on some stuff
get you some special emojis up in this
guy you know well you know they have
y'all let me ask the chat something real
quick
all right people in the chat if you ever
an emoji that you had access to that you
would want to use put in that chat what
you would want it to be mm-hmm yeah what
bushes yeah one nice because we working
on that for y'all you know let's what we
got so we all this has been taken care
of the iron bank is closed for the
months of October we gotta have some
kind of like Avatar key using the front
alert that's what we got a yeah man I'm
with all that man I'm with all that yeah
you might be you're crazy this week I'm
working with old school in the
background I don't know what's going on
but yes it's not it keeps you know what
he keeps doing it keeps bringing my mic
levels down and then I'm a four I'm
fighting with it while I'm talking to
bring it up so shout out to any OBS
experts this has been an ongoing issue
it sounds fine right now yeah but what's
gonna happen is I'm looking at device
properties and it slowly goes down it's
like some other application is
controlling it and I'm literally closing
out all my applications it's just into
sailing this is Alex Atala saccade I
just let go up under duress wrestle you
would have like I don't know so we'll
figure it out shot the old school style
he's in the background I smile live tech
support right now we work here trying to
work through it so if I go down in
volumes that's literally what's going on
I'm trying to fight to push my volume
back up and I keep see trying to fight
the system boy get out here but uh there
will be also of last week poll results
are in and the people have spoken to the
question with the recent internal shaker
departure of PlayStation executives from
Sony how concerned are you for ps5 for
the next generation the winner of the
three-way il people with 43% of the vote
was the no concern exclusives and
momentum of PlayStation 4 will continue
into the next gen group coming in at a
fairly close second place at only 30
percent of the vote was that I don't
care Phil dominus is on to something a
razor close last place at 28% was the
very concerned worst way to start a
generation see the ps3 group shout out
to all the lords are participated in
last week's poll Lord weren't you gonna
leave it says not as concerned as I am
about three for three
but I do gotta say this how do you feel
now that polls last week now in light of
new information you really feel indeed
honestly I can't wait to get into these
topics about this system because I don't
think y'all is confident and shall say
y'all I don't think there's gonna be a
lot of back pedaling in this podcast
that's just personally me shakin and I
got boxes baby
axes and I'm calling for everybody nice
cuz imma tell you about heaven in next
generation if someone actually a strong
line-up of topics but I've got some
breaking news that happen literally
before I LP went live for once it
happens before the podcast so we are
privy to it on yeah big shake-up hallo
infinite lead producer has left three
for three
let the second one or something like
this is the second one is this the
second person at the part you know I
believe it is our Mary Olsen you know
I'm saying and all she report that she
is let left three four three good
to LinkedIn page she's now I don't think
it's it's been like a fish thing now it
has but she is now working for a
midwinter entertainment this is the same
studio that our Josh Holmes the former
343 on head of video file Guardians was
in production design so now this is the
arm second departure you got we had a
super channel
I love with the twenty dollar super
check hashtag XO nineteen that's right
that's right you know what
you might be onto something the Lyla was
the one that was holding a camera for me
when we was playing X cloud I said got
over 15,000 views shut up you know I'm
saying friend in the round so we already
know what's up but uh yeah let's get to
it y'all like um you know obviously you
know this is big news a second departure
you know we all know how important you
know handle infinite is to the launch of
scarlet was announced to be launched
with scarlet so is this cause for
concern let's start with Lord addict yes
it is Wow thank you thank you that
definitely is there's just there's too
much weird stuff going on for not to be
mm-hmm I've been hearing for a little
bit that you know they it's not that
it's bad but I've been here's a lot of
confusion at 343 mmm so you know I I
don't know what's going on like you know
I said when we were talking about you
know the destiny thing where they might
go towards like a service game like
destiny I'm starting to think you know
like Scarlets launched like a spooky I
don't I don't know I think that that
might be the down the call like I really
do like honestly don't think that I
don't see them merely Microsoft think
Microsoft can afford halo think Erica I
don't think they can they recovered from
they recovered from language this is how
I see Xbox Xbox is j.cole and operation
is Meek Mill Wow right
make Nick mill gotta grind he got a do
it cuz if he don't he dead in the water
we doing it mmm you know if you playing
around you know this is a play with
other people money joking around listen
man stop would all that talk about
scarlet is all shaky knees when I ask
you this King in fairness you know can
we agree that the halo infinite launch
is extremely important to scarlet oh no
you know what I think it's which I don't
think is very important as the power
narrative I think um let's get that
super chat real quick yes sir
um we got our boy tip diamond for the to
LA super chat great show salute tip damn
it much appreciated
good thank you mmm um hopefully we can
live up to the expectations and um I
think honestly they have to knock it out
the park
mmm the hardware mm-hmm hardware at a
fundamental base has to show a larger
gap between that and the PlayStation 5
okay I don't games
remember this here's the thing the ends
ox-head the games in the beginning that
did matter nobody gave me dag on but
really I wanna hear this narrative so
you say that the power does matter Mona
if if your halos infinite power it's
just looking spectacular and that's
gonna over what what if what if I have a
repeat performance with Kay low fives
can
like we all felt let's say I'm proud of
our campaigns low mediocre listen to
this I don't even go with that I don't
believe that narrative I just believed
everybody wanted something to be
something else and it turned out to be
something other than they want it okay
right nobody else a rights for game
companies or games stories and and
everybody has their own leeway what how
something should go that's cool whatever
I'm like King trip and Xbox is the
caucus to pot hmm maybe Tupac shoulda
told thank you serve my boy I hit him
out the park I'm Barry Bonds with this
the repos to the chat okay anyway how
you look at the situation is halo is
intrical it is not going to be that it's
the hardware first of all it gotta look
better than the PlayStation let's not
lie thanks look like a box the
PlayStation was a box on a slip but that
squint made it look slick baby
didn't look better a lot of people don't
put enough emphasis behind how I get a
console looks especially color if you
don't like a black and white really
matters how that console looks like how
many did you hear at the beginning of
the jet yo Xbox one X like a VCR like
tearing it apart like literally it was
the ugly boxes it really does matter
like it does it was talking about the
aesthetics of a console as opposed to
the quality of a little boy
of that franchise vital to the life of
that franchise we're talking about if
the ecstatics of a console is will
impact sales they do it drastically but
they are people out there they like yo
that ain't putting that beside my DVD
don't I don't think it matters that long
is that launch you have the hard core by
mm-hmm articles gonna buy I think you're
gonna buy down now we're all like that
man like I don't know man let's get the
super stache out the JD game with the
files in which I halos the game not just
a game changer everything started with
Halo and PS 5 reign will end with the
problem with what people are not onto
just yet it's not good what if it's not
what if these changes again okay this is
the second kind of major no I
okay to answer your question right
because it may sound like I'm besides
definite annum innum and I'm showing you
okay and I'm doing a Donald Trump on it
okay I'm gonna answer you mmm-hmm
directly did does it concern me yes I
have to keep the same energy that I have
when I see other things happening in
other sectors with other people I have
to keep that same energy I don't want
y'all to think that I'm biased so I
don't want anything you know a system to
go anyplace I have lived through a lot
of consoles gyein right right but when
you say is it a good game is subjective
if you get enough of backing behind it
people can push a good game or a good
game to a great game by word of mouth
right but I honestly believe that
aesthetics and power is what starts it
off for the people that's on the fence
right now if you go in into the store
and they tell you oh you have the
scarlet and you have the the PlayStation
5 and the scarlet is more powerful and
it looks like this and the PlayStation
is less powerful and it looks like this
if the PlayStation is less powerful and
looks uglier hmm be honest would you go
for like Xbox one right but the
PlayStation 4 was more powerful and it
looked better I thought that they didn't
even try Xbox it literally looked like
an Xbox it's like I said you know I'm
not saying that that he has huge matter
but I am saying that how a console looks
does impact something because it's like
I said at the end of the jet people were
hardcore clowning on the Xbox would look
like a VCR I agree that it has effective
I just want us to rein back in one topic
with this halo infinity it's getting
back to infinite where we at with this
concern nurse nurse
addict are you concerned yes because I
want to see like look like at the end of
the day I don't think power is gonna
matter as much this gin is it matter the
previous chins because I feel like both
not maybe not much as Microsoft because
they just bought these studios but I
don't think we're gonna have a I think
we're gonna have decent launch titles
now i think i think we're proud most
likely we're gonna see our horizon zero
dawn i think that's gonna be a launch
title the reason that power mattered is
because consoles matter you know these
first party studios were making games
still but now i think we're gonna see a
steady flow game so that the whole
generation not just locked up the last
three in the first three is usually
that's how it is i think what we're
going to is we're going to see a better
thrush of games coming out quicker and
people are gonna be talking less about
the power or more about what's on the
console okay and Microsoft
I honestly think like I'm not gonna say
it's gonna it's gonna kill the brand but
if hey what comes out and it's a flop
I'm it's gonna trick it's gonna
tremendously hard it yeah and I I think
you're equally hurt if they have to
delay halo and it has already I think
that I think though delay scarlet in
general they can't come out with it
without it man they can every studio
they got and pause all the games and
have all those who you know work on that
on that game and don't and nothing
nothing
we did dr. Victor Alice tan with the
five dollar super chair this is three
four threes last chance they have with
the Halo franchise it might be time to
change the head bring in someone like
Ferguson if if something does happen
like I gotta be honest like that has to
happen like because I feel like you know
they've always got something bright and
it's something wrong right
you're I even made a video you know
bunchy versus 343 who makes better halo
Bungie make the Baader
the bender halos but at the end of the
day 343's always had an aspect of of
that Bungie never had yeah you know
they've always tried something that
worked but then the next game they just
acted like none of that worked and they
tried something different
the halo 5 had the best multiplayer but
the worst campaign in Halo 4 had one of
the best campaigns but one of the worst
multiplayer play shot the one bad
mother-- he was like they're capable he
said my number one concern about Xbox
turning it around is 343 leadership
everything else is lined up well halo
represents the brand more than the rest
of their games completely and that's
what I was gonna say okay a belief
Victor when Victor says that um 343
hasn't really done a real successful
Halo in okay if they don't really knock
it out the park like how gears is being
knocked out the park
I don't care what anybody said I thought
every last gears that came out was
stellar every last one you can base
anything on judgment you can say
whatever you want but I don't believe
they had a dip in amalgam I think gears
father's you know one of the best games
on xbox if not the best game on the I
think the generation is the best game on
xbox you know be honest with you but Oh
343 and I don't ever like to undercut
now mm-hmm
but if they do not knock it out the park
if they don't turn in something that is
heartfelt something that is powerful
something that is game-changing
yep look I have to put one of those
other develop team development teams in
charge of Enders franchise because
franchise is your lifeblood you can and
I dress something in the chat let's go
slow mo I'm so sick and tired you come
with this narrative that they it's like
they sign ball t studios and they have
no influence whatsoever in these studios
they let them rug but it's not like they
gonna be like yo we need five hundred
million dollars here it is don't don't
tell us what to do they still have to
approve the decisions and don't matter
if they let them out they read them they
still have they still have to prove the
decisions they have to like you have
literally went on these podcasts and
acting like they have no right
whatsoever to what these Studios do in
this chat I quote they can't change the
head remember they can't they don't
interfere with these studios they still
have a say on what goes on in these
studios and you act like they bought the
studio and they left they didn't come
back they don't check on them they'll
Spencer and in that in every one in
these studios they regularly visit these
studios why are they visiting but they
don't appear right so let's get let's
get your feedback on this man where are
you at with this latest news oh wow and
three people up in there we got 50 likes
it's a live show and shout out to that
one dude to keep put down hey I know who
you are he's out this [ __ ] he said with
the finalists of ACOG I prefer a
somewhat decent game than a remaster so
far Sony is too quiet about what games
are launching with the PS 5 ps4 was a
remaster machine ok is because they want
it to be formally announced before they
start announcing what's coming out on it
right it's just like Xbox that's the
reason you haven't seen fable or nothing
like that I mean they had to announce
that halo was coming out to get hype on
the system right but generally they
don't even do that right
continue sob you you about to get you
yeah I mean alright did the aesthetic
you guys are talking about I don't I
don't think it's that important like I
said especially at launch because you
have the hardcore buying and if they're
gonna buy the next system they're gonna
buy the next system I think it may be
matters more to to the the casual player
how it looks and what if friends are
saying is cool I think it launches
mostly hardcore but purchasing
especially at a $500 price point I don't
think they'll be talking like you or
like zealots like people they're like us
so if I'm not by the game saying look
I've always been one of the people I'm
going with as the better launch titles
most the time these games only have if
it comes out like a week before or the
same day and day like do we really have
time to play two consoles at the same
time I mean maybe you make you make the
choice I say you make the choice you
pick one or the other you know I know
King doesn't I know cog doesn't I don't
I don't which is barnable it's like
right yeah if I have time to play one
night they're gonna be I'm gonna buy
them day one that's just what it is like
I said from our perspective that
thinking the way it looks doesn't matter
too much honestly it could come out
looking like a big turd and like now by
you know this is what it is right I
think you know my xbox
so I power narrative like I said last
week I think you got a job yeah - Brad
let me read this skill for $5.00 to
purchase from Brett more than having a
great hero Microsoft needs a new IP that
your Alliance car that Microsoft hasn't
had that kind of game since the 360 I'll
agree with you they do need some kind of
new IP that defines the brand but we're
not gonna act like a well-made
critically acclaimed Halo won't go a
long way like a war is a very whole game
that was rebranded and it did numbers
for the ps4 yeah exactly like Microsoft
is not out here trying to push out these
new IPs maybe not hidden I mean they are
trying I'm I thinking honestly I think
the initiative is whatever they're
making is that game they're gonna try to
have be the face of Xbox at least in
this next coming generation you know but
I'm gonna tell you this that's T of
Thieves
it may not be change that you wanted
the game that you got and it's millions
of people are playing that game so it's
like everybody are playing that game
it's if it's not the game - anybody want
how come it always stay in the rear
common no you got to tell me how many
people is playing certain games and
what's the numbers behind that once you
explain it yes sir mmm Gillian's listen
all I know is that the issue with
Microsoft's first party the complaint
has been that it is lacking you know say
the complaint has been you know that
that's been the Achilles heel they went
out they got the studios we know about
that you know I'm saying we all felt
that we saw at e3 there the fact that
they announced halo Infinite has a
launch at we felt that was a strong move
we all all of the lords we were like yo
that's a strong wait a sec to jet off
all I'm saying is again we don't know
what's going on behind the scene maybe
they already have their creative
direction already in place you know
saying but it does make me you know have
a little concern that two leads have now
left you know and we're about to launch
a year out is it do them in guma I'm not
saying that I'm just saying it's
something I don't I don't often see and
I don't read it I don't read the chat
mm-hmm but because we're gonna see color
dinner is a new IP fine Xbox will never
happen
that's like McDonald's making a new
burger to beat the cheeseburger they did
it called the Wonder burger at the spawn
gotta stop dead stop me yes that's it
we're gonna stop reading the chat until
I see color
nothing is obvious my god he wasn't
having it
one thing that we not had a problem that
the Xbox brand has that they have to
deal with that
I don't think Sony has to deal with as
much is that people are real petty when
it comes to being like focusing in on
things that Microsoft says and then the
things that they did they end up not
being the case they I think they pay for
that more than anybody else I think
PlayStation can say something place that
can do a lot and not do enough they can
get and they can get away with it I
think that's what I'm saying when
Microsoft says something they better do
it because if not the repercussions seem
like they're always tired a Microsoft's
they they done that to themselves like
they keep backtracking everything
they've said like think about what
they've done this whole generation they
literally backtracked almost every move
they've made and even though it's for
the better it's still it's still a bit
regardless of your hands you're not
exactly let me tell you something you
know it looks bad at a person that
stands in their own defiance when
they're wrong that's what I cannot stand
Amit you're wrong take your guilt and
step off if you're wrong fix it I don't
like a company that is sit down and
stubbornness and go down in flames turn
this ship around and fix it if something
was wrong fix it you didn't get to
connect out the box throw it in the
bushes fix it I'll fix the power
narrative fix it take their DVD player
fix it put these games on fix fix your
problems don't sit there and your
stubbornness and go down in flames so
I'm not gonna condemn these guys for
switching it around and fixing it
because somebody else had a different
agenda I need you to do it to do it
right no question but if you're looking
at it from the outside you still like
you still say to yourself if you're if
you're looking at it from a pessimistic
point of view like these guys don't know
what the hell they're doing
mm-hmm you mean like I feel you listen
but a real company learns from their
mistakes going forward and make the same
mistake in the next generation right
well I mean yeah the proof is gonna be
to put
when this game launches and then you
know it's gonna be two trains of thought
one is gonna be all this was all for
nothing look the game was good
you're I'm saying because we had a
similar situation with gears five when
the campaign we got to be on in defense
of xbox right we've got to be honest
there was serious concerns about yes
five campaign and then look how that
turned out so I'm willing to give the
benefit doubt all I'm saying is my third
eye is open and we shall see how it
lands a day like it could we can't okay
you know when when the dude that got
demoted in he left I just saw that his
song bitter got the motor than leave but
there's too many people leaving this
studio to not look at like I said we got
to see hottest thing is gonna play out
man but that's what I got on the
breaking news oh hey look at it with
that we got a to chat go for you that's
for you that's the cake I was looking
over to the left
Kings million sorry but million listen
not one person just purchased the Xbox
wasn't just playing right now you look
around and say anyway look my god we got
you I see you but um yeah man we got
some PlayStation 5 news to discuss this
is where King gets all the revenge for
that last to God there Christopher Hart
Jake dubs and the rest of us still
watching God because I make you
announcement all riiii-- look you think
that J dad needs to make a cameo the to
somebody
put the X there because they know you
want to make a cameo hit hit me up in
the DS newsman so look basically
PlayStation 5 big announcement big
reveal wired.com again yet another
source of big playstation news I want to
shout out more to gaming down there my
man Hector out there putting it nice
little synapses of everything that was
talked about cuz it was a lot to unpack
so I'm just gonna do briefly play 65 is
officially the name it is out holiday
2020 console will come with a solid
solid state drive and I'll post to a
spinning hard drive fast to reach speeds
all that good stuff of SSD goodness mark
Cerny talking about one of the biggest
things which was nobody knew if rate
racing accelerated would be in the
hardware so it's in the GPU that is now
confirmed that was a big question we'd
all be thought about the physical disk
being 100 gigabytes rate read through
our 4k blu-ray player you know we talked
about revamped you are we talking about
haptic feedback new dual shock you're
gonna be saying they're talking about
game installations kind of almost like a
what was that joint software you'd be
able to selectively download multiplayer
and there was a name for it it was a
download term that we heard Xbox users
before intelligent delivery intelligent
the memory right getting basically a
form of that and then another big part
of the news which really was surprising
was blue point games working on an
exclusive PS 5 titles they're saying
it's a big one
they're saying other studios have deaf
kids you know meaning we did hear
conflicting things the last week you
know I'm saying there's some studios you
know we're still gonna hold up but not
gonna disrespect game I'm not really
putting too much into that blue point
well but we just put it out there so
look this is the news that it's out I
know thing has some additional news we
gonna get see as well but um let's start
off with the PlayStation 5 announcement
how are we feeling about it from what
we've heard where you at with this
adequate ah
I mean it's info info spice up I in the
next six months we'll know everything
else
I expect probably February March we'll
get some kind of uh some kind of
announcement not really I think they're
gonna do a showcase showing the railroad
Oh
we gotta get kid to read truth Kingdom
super check it's hilarious okay
PS part PS partnered up with square two
for the card for card readers will be
Activision then let you know my man is
down for this team right here cuz he's
been part of the knowing that a card
readers gonna launch a long side of the
system so you can wipe so you could play
your back kepada shout out to you sir I
think I can't believe you made that bet
you literally just gave your knees away
for free literal that is gonna be a card
read on the side I know they're not
having back a pet I know it I don't know
anything this you go down online I know
ain't gonna work
let's get to that but let's first start
with the PlayStation 5 announcement what
do we think adding like what is this the
first thing I wanted the other day
there's a lot of info going out about it
I mean it's kind of overburden to be
honest with you like a lot of info and
it's in a day yeah you know the Blue
Point thing I'm not gonna put a whole
lot of thing you know that could be
making a demon souls consider that big
I'm sure they consider every game
everyone's making speak I wanted to see
exactly you know when I see big I kind
of think they're making a new IP but
then that's not really their mo so it
might be just a big game that they're
remaking like a big big respective game
a lot of people thinking is something
like Metal Gear something like that I
don't know if that's gonna be the case
but you know it's exciting it's excited
I like to see how Microsoft's gonna know
was excited we don't let you talk here
in a second because you're gonna take
like 20 minutes up 20 minutes or nothing
just to protect
quick so let me handle that before we
ain't gonna say the rest the Oneg man I
want new IP from Xbox but no matter I
have always found games I enjoy Xbox
here's five outer worlds third party in
game past I will get a custom scarlet
infinite and PS 5 later King preach you
know what King he may be honestly but
anyway they wait for the smoke maybe
they know oh you know I was really
intrigued by the SSD on the PS 5 because
from someone that has been playing on pc
+ SSD makes a huge difference difference
so the biggest thing I care about I'm
sorry is that line up I don't care about
any of this stuff it's cool I like
looking at it I for one expect the next
Xbox expect the next PlayStation to be
an enhanced version of the stuff we have
now but what am i playing on that stuff
that's all I care Lord solve just about
the the specs of the initial
announcements how impressed with you
with the PS 5 no not not very honestly
like we didn't get actually wouldn't get
the actual specs of the machine that
tell you how powerful the machine is
everything else that they talked about
you know the 4k blu-ray drive they
should have had that from from miss Chen
like that obviously the SSD stop is is
and I would need more information on how
they're gonna utilize that obviously
they we talk about these instantaneous
load times that seems very interesting
to me but the control and the haptic
feedback honestly
it's you know it seems like it's an
improvement on what Microsoft did at the
start of this gen you know six years ago
and it seems like it's an improvement on
you know HD Rumble that switch did like
that stuff if you think about it and you
know when the adaptive triggers are
talking about now with the resistance
for when you shoot and stuff like that
if that's the bhakti works I be cool but
I just don't think it's something that
pasts past the first year of the
consoles life anybody's really gonna
care about okay it seems like like like
marketing filler talk like you know I
mean
but it seems that they're improving on
old things and then to me I want to see
how powerful the console is right so I
don't see what else did the USBC
charging yes that's a quality of life
improvement that thank God we no more
proprietary stuff you you know
let's see beyond that the Blue Point
stuff you know blue 20 was working on
something for them so you know that was
that um so beam on that like I want to
hear the actual specs of the console
what can this console do all this stuff
is cool but it's it did its its
drip-feeding stuff I want real real meat
shot the bad bit he said you got some
breaking news y'all yeah we touched a
halo if you just missed that bad but
that was our first lead off topic with
the halo infinite leave producer man we
definitely got that please catch the
replay but on yeah our King you want to
jump in or you want me jumping I want
you to do that because I'm gonna shut
the door on these boots head lock the
door not let them come back here imma
shut the door on my head pause just from
the pure bass numbers you know I'm
pretty sure I have to admit y'all you
know we all know this other say we all
know Microsoft towards the end of this
generation has made it their bit to
control the power narrative especially
with the X right they come out the X is
like boom this is what it is the most
powerful console yadda-yadda-yadda now
say what you made this could be
speculative this could be hyperbole I
could come at me but when we're at e3
when the scarlet reveal came out I
didn't hear the most powerful console at
that joint like hi 2x was no matter but
they said this is going to be the
definitive most powerful they kind of
shied away from that on marketing speak
now saying it's not I'm just saying I
didn't hear it so when I see the PS 5
i'ma keep it 1000 I gotta stand like I
didn't expect them to go this hard
especially with the hardware ray-tracing
didn't think they were gonna do that
door is gonna be a software-based
solution we know about the SSD we know
about all our stuff this ends the
navvies we know about all that
right but this thing feels kind of like
a beast so my question to you is
at this point can we admit this sounds
like at least a $500 machine any
important like this don't sound like
Sony is diet just you know jumping in
the mix like this sounds like yo they
are in in here on this power so my
question to you all is how hard can
Microsoft really go do you to one-up
them do you without breaking packet like
you think that it's possible Microsoft
might intentionally take a loss on the
console just to come out of better
competitive price and Sony because I
feel like from this generation and I'm
going in the next generation because you
know we have stuff that we didn't have
previous generations you have a digital
library that you can carry over they're
gonna have to have more compelling stuff
to convince people that went over to
Playstation to leave they library and
you know $100 difference might do that
I'm sorry hundred dollar difference will
do that they're having this strong
PlayStation 5 and it was $100 cheaper
would it mean something I think it would
it would take that did that that loss a
huge loss but you know they might take
that loss just just to get they foot
back at the door mmm
yeah I mean yes I've said we said this
from the jump when he started talking
about these consoles that they ain't
hustling 101 I mean if and if anybody
can take that bump to the bot to their
bottom line it's them add the deep
pockets right and if you think about it
I don't know if business going away from
the console slogan like they don't
really focus on it so taking $100 loss
and making that money back up with
software sells yeah and game pads there
we go they could do that I mean yes that
would be if you want you want a
guaranteed way to drop them I get III
and walk away the same way in 2030 you
know you do that you know the the best
thing that that Microsoft has going
next-gen is they can give or they can
give Halo Infinite without giving halo
infinite like they can be like we're
going to instead of bundling Halo
incident which
look it they're like well I think
bundling hello gamers yeah they all they
have to do is put it like three months
or a month to three what the game pass
like when did you play all that stuff
like this isn't groupís but do you think
that you know I don't want to go into
that because I'll just go down a
completely different rabbit oh you know
you know I think that there's a lot of
scenarios that could happen it just
depends on who's willing to do it right
we all know that there's only one person
who can do it the other person can't do
it this week let me tell you something
it's enough for this rhetoric for this
hyperbola is enough of this crap that's
going on the people out here shoveling
snow we're gonna fix this up let's fix
this up alright so this week on Twitter
if you was watching my feet um you got a
chance to see me shut the door people
hate there's a lot of these dudes when I
hear talking about plastic control
alright so you know Christopher bare
witness to what was going on there
witnesses I exercised my exorcism
understand these dudes right here I told
you before you're messin with Big Daddy
Warbucks now Big Daddy Warbucks don't
woke up this was your biggest fear this
has been your biggest fear so I decided
to do something that y'all dudes did not
want me to do put up the stock numbers
mm-hmm now your money looking funny in
the light now now that you see that you
what you really trade in that and the
only thing that's propping you up is
that you sold 125 million see the police
is outside right now let me just
interrupt you for two seconds yeah couch
gaming they won't be taking on jollof
they usually end up making anywhere from
thirty to fifty dollars off profit off
these games it off these consoles anyway
so they would be making like maybe a
fifty dollar loss like that's not a lot
considering they've done this before but
can you continue with your your stuff
all right I gotta hear this you say
Microsoft is trading at one thirty one
thirty eight right Sony is trading at
fifty bucks
right $52 now if your stocks is kind of
shaky for a big company and every time
they're talking about buying and selling
Sony's on the chopping block you have to
understand that the system that you get
next year might be the Amazon five you
know um so you guys is out here champion
something that doesn't look right in the
light the money is looking funny you
sold as your PlayStation fans and listen
I purchased more PlayStation stuff than
all of you so I'm gonna put that right
there for you you know look at that how
would that go if you go through my
Twitter feed you can see I have five of
them and I was selling them um anyway so
Jade up in that comment section
extracting his head and yeah he know he
know what it is he purchases just as
much as me I my support just as much but
if you sold all these systems you have
to Game of the Year candidates won Game
of the Year won Game of the Year
candidate they can flip-flop either way
you were stellar throughout the this
whole generation as far as pushing a
narrative that got around to a lot of
people you became the leading platform
and at the end of the day you only prop
young your company up by this sale and
you still be in shaky people are still
leaving CEOs are still walking out the
door people in the background is telling
you that stuff ain't looking right
coming into the next system we've never
had issues like this this is not the
same and trust me when you read this
stuff where this smoke there is fire now
I keep the same energy with 343 I told
you I am concerned I am worried about a
game that is supposed to be that game
that's supposed to push the next
generation for them but just like cog
said just like a sovereign said just
like addict said all those games going
game pass this is the only system that
in the box you're going to get two
hundred plus games off the RIP hmm so if
they take a loss in sale they already
know they got you in service right so
over a period of time they're gonna make
that money up over service right so do I
believe that system gonna be more more
powerful than the PlayStation could be
but I know it's going to come in at same
cost or cheaper and they can take the
loss opposed to the other company whose
stocks aren't trading as high thing I
want to say hundred and twenty people I
appreciate everyone coming down you
definitely hit that like button if you
don't mind we got a two dollar super
chat from six six six six nine he says
King get your millions back how you feel
about that King we got a shot from
breath stops is over Microsoft stocks
how you feel but that came well I can
say this where is your pre-order for
stadium all I want to say is back your
stuff up by hellbug I think people want
you to use the fraud alert yeah well you
know what I'm not gonna use it on breath
because braaap actually walk back no I
think they want you to use on yourself
oh me if you think what I'm telling you
is wrong I want you to think about
everything I've said on this podcast and
everything I've said has came true
except for this card reader yet when
that thing come out I'll be like oh my
god he was not playing I went to put my
PlayStation 4 game in and a dollar sign
popped up and say pay now think what but
I owned the game yes
we own the rights to allow you to play
it on our systems listen at the end of
the day and who's in a better position
in my opinion going forward is these
guys Sony did not tell you anything that
Microsoft wasn't doing a 4k blu-ray
player done that haptic feedback
controllers that's being done by other
people what did you say Oh fast hard
drive Microsoft said that but King are
you not impressed that at least on paper
it seems on par from what we know about
Scott we interface to Scarlett we don't
know everything there's still time we
don't know right
Scott I could literally come out
tomorrow and say we got this we got this
more flaps and we got you know more or
less I get that but can you say that
right now just from what we know the
Romish out the Lord Mads he's going to
uh flaws he gave me gotten that like
don't it feel like they like right here
power guys okay so you then I think that
Scarlett would be our overall beef and
crush it in power right I didn't think
that I still think it'll be more
powerful I don't think it's going to
crush it in power for the simple fact
they've been made in the same labs
basically these dudes is walking down
the street and getting the same part
these systems is going to be
interchangeable to be honest with you
and these last systems is daggone almost
interchangeable right what what a ball
down to is some fine-tuning inside
optimization today very fax when you got
to the X the X was that you know who I
got confidence in you everybody's
sitting like you ride for Xbox you rot
no I like to underdog I really do I
really do I have confidence in the
leadership mmm okay so when I'm looking
at a general going into war who can I
stand behind you know who can I back a
person that changes everything that was
wrong going forward or the people that
either abandon ship or stay the same
course and don't fix anything because
there's two stuck in complacency because
they're winning has allowed their throne
to rot so I can't back you I cannot back
you I cannot put nothing behind you
knowing that I know you are going to
fail because I've seen it so many times
if you don't change you're destined to
go the way of the dinosaur mm-hmm you
you say did not complacent Christopher
but what what wisdom innovation you D
just literally announced something that
the Xbox already have if you want all
that stuff right now go buy X so
basically your point is King because of
Phil's being able to turn around the
Xbox from the plight it was in and the
direction in services you like the way
it's going you feel from a leadership
standpoint
they're stronger going in as opposed to
what we're hearing right now and I guess
we should transition at some point as
far as um you know with the the layoffs
and stuff that's going on with Sony
interactive entertainment do you so do
you want to touch on that unless yes yes
okay yes yes I would love to touch on
that because one first of all I don't
make light of anybody losing their job
and not being able to feed their family
and no point in time do I am I happy
that anybody had sown it first of all I
don't like Sony Finland I don't like
Nintendo film I don't like Sega failing
I don't like NEC feeling this is how the
companies go but just the same way some
of these people have lost a job Aaron
Greenberg and a wonderful staff and
Microsoft has that sounds like we got a
bag that is a bag well you know the
olive branch went out and said listen
yeah olive branch went out and said we
have openings you know they don't have a
money problem yes shout out the
greenberg when they did yes you are
correct
I apologize they don't have money
problems there's no money problems on
Marcus off there's nobody talking about
Dignam they might be purchased out so if
you're looking for that job security and
stuff like that go apply over there
because they definitely put their hand
out to those people that was
unceremoniously dismissed they did not
know it was coming
it wasn't no memo you know and all this
shake-up and stuff is happening in this
is at what point are you guys gonna
really look up and say you're worried
when is it gonna happen because I'm so
sick and tired of you guys talking about
all as well and you got water up to your
nose mm-hmm all is not well but here's
the thing shout to bad bad games he said
if Sony was complacent they wouldn't
have changed their stance on the
services cross play and cross
progression so he's saying they are
adapting to do what Microsoft is doing
so shouldn't that put them in the
mixture in that make them now they're
not complacent that they're looking at
Microsoft as direction is the direction
to go okay mm-hmm all those people that
are in place now are playing ball with
Phil I told your last podcast you
save me time fulfilled Dominus Maximus
Spencer and what point in time are you
gonna just stop calling it a PlayStation
and call it an Xbox let me get that let
me guess - holy Sh out - Jamison you
know say we spent too much time talking
power in specs only hardcore segment
cares about that and follows that info
the masses care about games all that
matters I think I'll take you on to
something yeah I think that is key you
know I'm saying and that's why ya mean I
am a little concern with the halo
infinite news you know I'm saying I am
concerned about I want to know what
PlayStation 5 launches with I think
that's very important you know I'm
saying because again if Halo infinite is
good I think that's you know that's
their pinnacle franchise I saw be
curious not saying that's when he
doesn't have anything we know Sony got
bangers they said no I'm just curious as
to what their launch lineup would be in
comparison to what you know Microsoft
made a shameless - with a multiplayer
revamp I'm talking what I'm talking
about is what they promote the PS 5 with
right like that's what I won't know
because the promotin goes to Kashima
with PS 5 we don't know that you know it
could be a cross-generational title well
they said they said that they've keep
promoting it as a ps4 title so it's
coming out at the end of the gen I'm
sure it's pray more than likely that is
not talking about the vs. for the PS 5
that's gonna add that game in it oh I
would say yeah I would say it's gonna be
that right it's gonna be that and like I
like cogs said that last it was part two
with the most question you know that
that's gonna be there mm-hmm the first
that's what they're doing
I'd have probably had to go with the
xbox like right cuz like at the end of
the day it's like I don't want to I want
to know the games that you are pushing
this product with like well you got a
ghost of Kashima you know maybe you guys
are probably onto something there but
like the Last of Us - that's gonna be
out and bam you we're right
well I do are they really gonna be
pushing that in in November I gotta give
a shout-out to Porter oh yes [ __ ]
this this is what I'm talking about you
see what you don't understand is that's
a real guy right there
mm-hmm shout-out to him - you know - to
come and to stand up for his his the
company that he backs he's been back in
and he's been back in it with facts and
you know y'all y'all guys think that we
don't follow each other we don't listen
to each other we don't you know play off
each other we do there's no hate inside
this realm what you guys have to
understand is y'all got to stop hating
each other fighting each other just look
at the facts great games is all over the
place right great games has to be
purchased all over
I brought a Nintendo stuff on my
playstation stuff I buy Xbox stuff but
like addicts said if that's what they're
coming with he's going to go this way
people think I'm joking like I saw
someone in the chat say I'm going with
Xbox either way I'm going whatever title
was appealed to me if they mess up a low
chances are you're still probably gonna
next month because I'm haha but you
don't like if a station want that money
for me day one they gonna have to show
me why they need to give okay and
horizon zero thought so a complete ban
lesss off let's get to the second part
which is what King brought up which is
about delay us I know this is a big
point of contention with you in attic
last week so my question to you is now
that we're here in the reports you know
what I'm saying you know obviously you
know the power struggle stuff and then
you know got people are apparently there
seems to be a complete shift in
direction you know I'm saying
with Sony EU and them going kind of like
to a us focus and a lot of these guys
are laid off apparently once the wired
article went live as far as the whole
PlayStation 5 news so where are you at
you know I'm saying as far as that and a
practice this supposed shift you don't
say as far as focus from that you're
saying that's a shift that's been
happening for years if you if you
remember I do you guys remember the
first time that a console didn't launch
in Japan first right remember when that
happened and we were like what the hell
going on and what happened is is that
when Japan started to shift from from
this loving consoles into now being more
of a mobile market right America took
over the Americas took over in Europe
took over as as the primary markets for
these consoles so at that point you now
you're getting we're getting launches in
these territories first before Japan and
now basically you see everything across
the board you have Universal launches
across the board for the most part right
I mean so the fact that they're
addressing this market first and trying
to focus everything on this market makes
a whole lot of sense that from a
business standpoint it makes a whole lot
of sense that's the way it should they
should have been working towards this
slowly from the beginning of this
generation
now the that bothers me is that the way
they've done it now with these changes
at the end that's why when we talked
about how it seems like Ladin was the
one that was resistant to this sort of
stuff is because I don't like the fact
that you do make moves like this and
drop more out right it mean it's a
morale dropping thing when Europe has
always felt they had a certain place in
the Sony hierarchy and then they drop
announcements about the next PlayStation
without even letting them know and then
the same day they let these people go
some people they let go on out right
some people they made re-interview for
further so the same job for the same job
they had different crews missions right
to that
that'll that's a morale killer I don't
understand why they they do it's like
they announce a positive and a negative
to like kick like they look he kind of
like it doesn't really cancel out it to
the media
you see all this good stuff and you say
oh wait they'll a crack I was just about
to say because it might not be around by
the end of the Jews oh yeah but I think
I think I'm gonna get you give right
back to you so I think I can make it a
good point I think like Mark like I'm
say marketing 101 but um but you know
what you do like spin like pop in a new
rule of advice is if you are about to
really drop some I don't say horrific
news but some negative news that
wouldn't shine you in a good light
sometimes you want to brace and soften
that blow with positive in the sense of
hey let's give them the place
five announcement now and then also
solitaire if you're something going on
to the background it doesn't kind of a
deal and I will say there is a little
bit is some I don't say genius to it but
that is known in political you know
social spaces how to do that but guess
I'll continuing it just feels like once
again I always say this you you're
pulling you're grabbing defeat from the
jaws of victory you didn't need to do
that and this is something you knew
needed to be addressed
you could have dripped feeded this
slowly and and have these changes happen
in the background in a way that that
doesn't feel like like it's all
happening at once and you're kind of
scrambling right and it's just like it's
just one of those things it just it
looks bad but at the end of the day the
bottom line I do think that shift needs
to happen it's been happening the past
ten years you think it needs to happen
no no I think this is the primary market
this is the primary market this you need
go at it for the first time alone to me
the vision needs to be centered on this
market I really I really do I gotta get
it yourself don't ever fight let me go
so you know no I hear we avoid weekly
thing about it solve the reason why I
disagree is because in my opinion home
team for Xbox is always being us right
Japan is bits Japan we know what's
what's going down over there you know
Stan so we know the new approach is
services cloud you know ISP contracts we
know project as cloud is supposedly
supposed to handle that supposedly right
but from a console standpoint to me why
did another reason why 360 eventually I
mean lost when it came to Xbox one when
Xbox one loss is that European region
note their lack of focus in the European
region for whatever reason and kudos to
Sony you know I'm saying now I don't
know if they shout to a point of rocket
shot the bad better here yeah school me
who is responsible for really I don't I
don't know necessarily if it's late in I
don't want to give him all that but
clearly someone really put that Sean had
when they launched in all those
countries and Microsoft focused on like
exactly those lots of laughs morning so
- my joint like my thing is I'm
concerned for Sony that the European
division is saying hey we're not getting
the news they're seeming they're
switching the focus off we're getting
late laid off you and I'm saying and and
now the focus is they're dominating
that's what yeah that is one of the very
few that's one of the few places that
are they they're destroying Microsoft
ads like obviously you got the Japan
it's for what I'm supporter by Kaz Hirai
yes Castle Rock shouted chief Tommy said
mr. new co-founder of mixer just lived
that's real oh you know what they did
like they like ninja taking all the
shine my thing is not diminishing the
market per se right but what I mean
restructuring so that the core message
the control of the message from the most
popular market which would be the more
the US market right um that's my
thinking that's just my thinking oh but
again not necessarily diminishing the
amount of people you have over there
it's strengthened marketing to that
particular market it's not that but when
it comes to figuring out who's at the at
the forefront at the head of the message
I think that's that's where they've been
going here's the thing and I want to
shout out yellow it's still out yeah
sorry I don't know cool so that thing is
the thing I want to shout out Andy
Robinson
um he's I believe with VGC news he has
some pretty I don't say damning tweets
but he broke the story you know I'm
saying in reference to the whole EU
thing and he said look he said I it's a
disappointing story break
I'm told that Morales ie Europe is
through the floor as the latest of the
layoffs head you said the feeling is the
u.s. is running the show from now on he
said those are expressed but
they said those he spoke to express
bewilderment really that is happening at
PS 5 then he goes on to say this is it
new it's been going on for a year
I really hope PlayStation 5 doesn't lose
the regional flavors that built the
brand but from the outside it feels like
the spirit is being dismantled anyone
who has worked in or around Sony Europe
has been an amazing institution as
responsible for so much of what we
recognize PlayStation 40 that's and you
my concern that is my model that they
built isn't part of the reason in my
opinion place was your one but you know
what else like this might be another
case of us we keep saying this on IOP
Sony really is trying to get too full of
themselves like now they're literally
like we don't even care about the Year
districts like and maybe like they
they're lighting that you know those you
mean Ryan you me Ryan is basically I
would say yes isn't that staff like that
you know how it goes and influencer and
stuff like that is when you call it when
you do any type of influence you have to
talk to the people who do your country
mm-hmm yeah you know Europe is
definitely one of the countries that
keep them in those NPD's yeah so if they
are literally not you know if the morale
is there and they're not even getting
news like they work for a company so I
even telling them stuff it does feel
like they're shifting to you know we
it's not necessarily we don't care about
the year it's no point but we're
focusing on a mayor all right in their
defense and let's play devil's advocate
in their defense we do agree that cloud
and services is the long-term play right
right so that's what is it Ryan the
person that said back impact nobody does
it
yeah you said that backwards Lee he's
kind of change course now based on Liddy
well with Playstation now we could kind
of see in any playing ball went back
with compat you know I it is it a full
admission no but I look at it as when I
see the PlayStation now and some stuff
not day in date but a lot of older stuff
there and the server's going down but
anyway enough of that my thing is you
know is it an old-school regime versus
the new-school regime and
do agree that the news we most of us
agree the new school regime with the
cloud of services is the way to go for
the future but is this at the expense of
what built Sony for this general it
might be much today they might start
breaking down on stuff that made them
mad are were already saying there's only
like for Sony Japan is leading the show
like you said it's always been Microsoft
is hair or Sega wouldn't win okay
Nintendo's in Japan Sony's in Japan Sega
was in Japan Sega of America when they
got a control of it they really
destroyed the Sega brand all we see in
the same type of thing happened now
whereas Sony of America is getting a
hold of certain things and it's not
looking right you know I feel that the
European market is that's what put them
over the top to be honest with you the
way that they but it's got a true bike
yourself didn't focus on EU because
Kinect require translations for
everything dumb or II's right yeah that
wasn't that member cuz Kinect was in the
bottom jooge and they had to get it
couldn't get it in time
you order some pics with BG like you
know people can disagree and that's fine
but I'm really starting it you know it's
little things like this then lead to you
having a misstep when the gen starts hmm
do you think they're gonna have a mr. I
don't I don't know if they're gonna have
a mr. I think that they might have some
small missteps yeah but you know if they
keep in the if they keep filling
themself like this it could lead to a
big just don't know what it is is that
you know change is always in the
obviously changes disruptive and this
this is a change that feels like it's
disrupting what the Sony brand is in a
way no he exactly that now the thing is
and we've discussed this before right
he's growing with the future there's no
guarantee that they've boned themselves
up to the point now with
do you have to say okay there's no Gary
and we discussed this before there's no
guarantee they put themselves in the
proper position on the of their own
accord to be able to be 100% ready for
that future at least ready for that
future in the same way that Microsoft is
that Google is right so it's it feels
what it feels like it's it feels like
it's a it's a switch that's happening
too quickly right and it almost feels
like the core the core aspects of what
Sony and PlayStation was this this
generation like the absolutely you know
the great single-player stuff the great
first party stuff it feels like it's
being attacked in a way dad I don't know
it's just I understand what you guys are
saying it'd be just because they're
following suit with what everybody seems
to think is the way to go right I mean
it's the way to go for them a good point
I think is the way to go for them solve
them because there's only one way to be
honest it means a lot especially the
start of a generation if narrative means
a lot that's at the start of a
generation it doesn't look good if I
just start with generation you come off
like you're playing follow the leader
and you would leader always been
following the leader accident champions
accident champions but they have always
capitalized on the mistakes of others
and always shined they they have the
best rebuttals in the game in fact
remember though though this is how we
share games like you know they might
drop you know what's funny
how much different this gaming industry
would be if Sony went first and
announced they cards first why it up
properly that's how a master tactician
sets it up let the fool go first and you
come right but a Microsoft to fool
yeah we all agreed that we didn't like
the Dan matric era and the way now is
the the whole marketing was just TV TV
we all agreed that oh oh boy you know
like we all agree the messaging was
horrible no he was bullet his stove and
Sony came by that was the endless
freestyle I've ever seen where two CEOs
to Mexico that said this is how we trade
game oh that's that was the nail in the
coffin
nobody wanted to connect brother listen
when they went further that's the most
savage thing I've seen them do blog
awesome it was it was awesome and they
didn't have any and they had that they
did that mad that's nice it was nice I
want this year I don't want Microsoft to
reveal all the cards at e3 I'm on Sony
to come next and then at the end of the
week Microsoft say oh yeah the prices
such as such and such and such thank you
first I'm below something is gonna piss
people off right has it has anybody said
where our bar is going no I think you go
on Stadium whoa no I told you okay
earlier right okay me and addict talked
early about the Mike Ibarra move mm-hm
and I'm not saying that that's not a big
moved of course that's a big move okay
it is a huge move he's the face for the
company he's been the face of the
company or one of the faces in the
company for 20 years
all right he's been in Christopher Hart
do you really want him over there with
you you don't want him over there and I
wouldn't take them if he came knocking
on my door from a competitive standpoint
no but this is where it's a little bit
different
then the Ladin leaving it was official
announcement yes I agree okay and he
explained that I'm going to a better
place or to a different place I'm
extending to another company
I believe that company is stadia I
believe that he would be better fit
there
now being that iron Lords are privy to a
lot of information that we don't give to
you guys we can't you know out of
partnership friendships out of respect
to people we don't say a lot of things
and all I'm gonna say on this thing here
is how much did you see of him in the
past year you know we know that you know
my crew had changed yeah I'm saying and
definitely you know as far as the stage
presents and things of that nature he's
kind of was gonna say so cause he was
doing other things in his role then he
changed you know I'm saying during the
last I would say three years I'm saying
um first of all salute the Mike Ibarra
you know I'm saying good friends your
home you know had them on and you've
been in the chat I'll pitch out a few
times and they're on you know we'll see
what happened is what I mean I'm saying
I will say this King that I do agree is
the difference the problem I have with
the Ladin situation has always been his
weird I would say weird but that curious
silence right to this day not a tweet
not a normally it's a mutual thing it's
the company saying yes leaving and then
hey thank you for your time that's
generally business 101 when you're
moving on to the next opportunity the
fact that one entity has said it he has
not we here behind the scenes between
the Ryan and him struggle it does leave
a lot of questions no one knows
we just throw questions I don't like did
you guys get the scripture no please get
it all right so we got a to know first
off you know a hundred and forty people
in here right here oh that's a number
for us hit that like but you guys I know
I know we got you guys
in here early when it's not early now
but an hour later I definitely
appreciated but we got a $2.00 super
chef instead she says like he said
Sony's next Xbox is going to be shaky oh
my ok you got a little army behind you
man we got a couple more topics but
listen this is a chance we got to see
what's gonna happen
you know I'm saying how this whole thing
plays out very interesting for the start
of next gen but I'm not ducking
anybody's um
anybody's a associate I'm not having
that same energy with Mike Ibarra leavin
and mr. Lee I'm leavin fact all right
I'm and tackle it both the same way I do
not like stuff like that happening with
face of companies but I do say on
official announcement by the person that
was leaving and the company is a little
less shaky opposed to somebody like
they're just leaving and you get in a
tweet that's kind of different Tommy's
gonna tell with these moves and all
these moves and all these departures you
know what's gonna happen and it was
these moves the right moves but we are
going to move on Lord at it who is Chi
in India's v as a boat well it's not
really cheating people are to be honest
with you there is a couple things okay
right now coalition are the people that
make gears they are actually putting in
some crazy ban hammers or here and like
we're talking like the PD ban hands okay
we ain't talking like you know get out
of this little giveaway thing we talkin
about you ain't play not game for a year
ban in us so you know that they did say
in the tweet that of the people that are
getting these harsh penalties there for
previous activity so it could be from a
you know we do have PC with gears v so
they could be using kind of some kind of
mod or some kind of cheating mechanism
and that's why they're getting banned I
don't think it's necessarily that
because most of the time when you cheat
like that you get banned for for good so
for right now to my standards
people are getting banned from a month
up to a year for quitting early so
I want to bring to the to the round
table to the lords isn't it I want to
know do you think this is fair do you
think that uh if and if you don't think
this is fair I want you to tell me what
would be fair lord sighs I mean I don't
know man like it's their game to handle
this day see fit and you know I don't
know how true this is but oh but I want
to bring to use if you spend $60 on
regardless if it's all game best game I
know you gonna bring that up $60 on this
60 bones oh they should be in the band
you for you
keeper shorty if you keep cheating are
we gonna say quitting is cheating if you
could if you're quitting you about to
take that LS daddy
that's cheating let's get it I'm
constantly do this you're about to take
the L you quit you care if you leave a
game 20 times did you give me magma
every time you land you getting very
funny literally cutting half the game at
the game but the funny thing is yeah
again like the game pass thing does have
some merit you really you know you just
paid $1 for whatever you pay for a lie
it's a straight line
it isn't live but I will say this it is
their game to do with as they please and
if they feel that is a purchase this I
mean Cole was during the game as they
please soon in the game on your servers
yeah this is only rank how did they get
these service oven me purchase it in
this game I don't think it works that
way but yeah I think you won I'm the
backbone of the company if I choose not
to purchase your game you don't get
those numbers up so you sent me abandon
let's say give it tax evasion time hold
on
we clearly are split document or any
made of numbers clearly spit that split
down the middle how it normally is
making versus YouTube that's always um
so how would you guys handle this yes I
look at it like is a year to two years
excessive yeah it's ridiculous i grits
but there is it thing he did before i
come back where where you play soon as
you launch up the motel player it's
called the term of service and you kind
of sell your rights over to adhere to
what they it's their shop they're like
yo you coming in our house Rocco Rocco
right wait a good point he said let it
dude
use the n-word and they only get so K I
seen in the comment you know people were
saying is cheering is not you it squiddy
but here's my one in the chat if you
think she acquitting is she here's my
but you if you don't think here's my
song on with Quinn again I play a lot of
competitive multiplayer in destiny
here's my thing one of the worst
feelings in we're playing as a four-man
team or three-man team and next thing
you know do drop cuz you're down to all
and it's just you three three four to
lead three that is the worth but you
know it's coming so I played I had honor
and play through the whole match even
though I got a disadvantage one somebody
died in this house had been banned for
three days on destiny for quitting out
with people that hi girl are like so so
you know I do have a little thing in
this life if you I feel like if you did
people trying to act like only people
getting disconnected or getting back
let's be real here Fargo and let's keep
it up down like the the the studio was
like yo not only was they saying they
standing on it
they was clapping back they said nah
look Ginny he did this he did his 25
times
look like they had your rap sheet like
there was no getting out of it they had
your rap sheet what you was doing while
you did it so don't try to act like what
kind of question for you do you think if
someone is a repeat offender like 10
times they've been Ward multiple times
did they unbanned everyone no I haven't
played gears in a while is this on the
menu you get warned that you might not
come back to this for two years
that's my question right before they buy
the do it listen man you do that again
the first thing the first thing that
they lock them up effort they badly
spooked it right lock them up I two
years I listen we were on their job we
gonna let y'all go right now but if you
do this again you're getting the two
family getting that strong pool and you
gonna have to hold me nothing man I spit
in the face of authority and Birch's
this game you can't tell me what to do
with my game in the game throw a bomb
and then jump my business this is our
house you gotta wipe your feet on a
carpet you got a plane you know
something you said something in the
beginning and you said that we sign
those terms of the game right is there
option to decline thank you shout out to
everybody in here to just keep clicking
yeah yeah yeah whatever whatever you
gonna get to the game when they be like
oh I quit and then they get banned for
the year you know I want my money back
you're not gonna shut me down for a
whole year from a portion of a game that
I paid for with my bucks I don't care
how listen you baby you're always saying
he came on game pass oh no if you come
so if you got a game passing you know
they push you out the back
like you been too much back to a point
Russian is making I want to bring this
up this is real dough he clown him he
said this is a deathblow two gears fire
right we know he clown it but the whole
thing is this I will say there's no way
he's onto something good look here's the
thing
you don't say it's on to something
elicits color but how will we track it
ain't on nothing but what what I will
say is there is something to be said if
you banging cats for two years really
confident that like how many people you
gonna keep doing this because you not
okay how many do they got playing this
game it biggest Oh dues Alpha Chi
numbers must be bananas because it
really got like 5 million people playing
a million this is only rank you're only
getting banned from ranked ok you can
play casual you can play all that stuff
so you know maybe it is a little bit
more acceptable if they keep telling you
over and over again now how many times
because if you bad something for two
years
let's be real here you banned that dude
from Gears 5 right so do you think that
how many offenses would it take to
before you be like get out of here you
out - I'm down I don't think I think I
think you get that banned for the day
you get the banned for seven days you
get banned for a month and then you get
banned for you for six months and then
you get banned for you I think that's
fair oh I thought y'all was talking
about legs cuz I don't play that stuff
don't use clappers crap if you keep
leaving games it is affecting the
overall experience where everybody so I
think you leave
you leave that the first time you get
banned for like the 30 minutes whatever
it is you leave the second time it's a
day it's the third time it's a week the
four times a month and then the fifth
times six months in the seven times a
year escalation to it like the new mode
big escalation for a year and then and
there like a scream pops up and you
press a it's like but we got placed it
over here for you I will agree I think
the fair call is probably like a
progression you know as opposed to such
an extreme you know two years on grip
now now that I understand it because I
didn't I cuz I don't care about that
multiplayer yeah so but the fact now did
you tell it me first of all is a
sanction fight that's the same thing on
a sanctioned fight you deserve to get a
year but off the RIP if you have u
squared up you sign your name on a
dotted line like we're gonna meet a
Tuesday at 12 o'clock and then you run
out the back door you deserve to get the
bare hands casual dudes is like they
left they want to go make a sandwich
moves like begin bad for ya they come
back I wish they would have came out a
little bit more with a little bit more
details of why people are getting banned
for year because they said previous
stuff so we don't know what they could
have been dallisa
a lot no evidence it was she had your
rap sheet they went when you try to
complain you try to talk to the judge
she was like nah fam you did this on the
22nd it said they had she be that person
you know you doing some illegal pirate
you call the cable company like we got
you IP family no no what it is video
last time we got a rolls get a body
luminous no technology for Google
Stadium are you sorry
are you saying he's the equivalent to
speaker to kognito ladies bill bogus
got some new cutting-edge tech now we
gotta get it
why don't we we got we got a super
Cherica let's go ahead and get take this
no we got a hundred and twenty people
think everyone hit start like that like
God did Shia by dollar super check from
Grant
obviously he's Brett you know let's see
what he says
I was banned by the Coalition for
quitting I had I had to do you know what
you know what then you might not have
been onto something rap you want playing
gears like that anyway so let's go ahead
and move on let's move on but Lord um
loss of man is going on with this new
technology so edge magazine the VP of
engineering stadium as bakar he made the
bold statement that eventually he
expected stadia to be more responsive
than local councils so and the way by
which they're they plan to do this
they've coined as negative latency so so
basically what negative latency is is
that they say that what they they
they're gonna set up a server which sort
of can predict latency occurred I
couldn't say this was a straight face
latency is gonna it can be some predict
it can basically predict the latency was
happening between the server and the
player and then there used certain
whatever methods to sort of undercut it
which is I mean honestly this is what
they have to do right they have to do we
have to trick they have to trick the
river and it is
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so what role Adela can predict you know
I've done so many commands they just
predict the whole ray for me and I can
just sit down and eat a sandwich y-you
know true they got Cleo in the box you
could beat games like blood-borne that
comes over because they go do it in
production Mingo Norma died so they're
gonna kill me so just taking the games
from people imagine playing destiny of
people like Mia kognito I'll use emotes
all the time like when we're not
supposed to we're gonna be like jumping
up and it's go to an emo he's like whoa
you did an email last time you stopping
by before I clock back in my brother
said you really break this is
cutting-edge and so they're basically
saying they're by study of this buffer
and being it would using learning an AI
they can predict they can predict but
trust us to the point that will help
speed up the game another one can trick
the server is by running the game at
super high frame rates which would
translate to a super steady 30 frames
per second that's what they say I said
is better than not you've got in your
hands if it would have said it
translates to a 60 frames per second
local experience I'm like okay 30 I'm
not jumping for joy for that like I
don't it's not drama so I'm not sold
um the machine learning stuff is real
but I think these these
specially the next consoles why not
they're gonna be using it to improve
right like resolution and stuff like
that with the deep learning and stuff
like that right oh yes can they predict
certain button presses if they have
algorithm and you know but you know what
have you got a finger to read yeah
exactly
so does this mean if I die negative
legacy if you mess up they did we gotta
let me jump cuz I was cooking so now
here's out to the og are the xbox Seamus
blackly there he had a hot freestyle and
gets to do with this so Cheryl he said
this is some unfortunate message a
messaging on many local Google needs to
let game dev check some of a talking
point before they let them loose in the
wild they're smarter than this so he
goes on and just say this is horrible
and basically you know I'm saying this
or let some fraud or II hear it alms now
in solves defense with what the point is
well as far as the tech the tech had
existed Microsoft have talked about this
tech from wave a mile deep learning for
a long time and it's real but when you
do you know predictive stuff when you
when you're talking about using it to
predict button presses in a game liking
you you don't really know how people
play like you know I'm saying again the
the learning part of it is that it
learns patterns right and I don't know
if it's able to learn individual
patterns of individual players like
that's that's kind of crazy but yeah you
don't be crazy if it learns patterns
when you like drinking and playing game
you're so I was drunk
like it's weird you know that stuff
maybe with enough information 10-15
years down the line it'll be something
that really works yeah but it doesn't it
feels like it's marketing speak to try
to get people on board like faster than
local
that's a bit that's a bit yeah that's
what they lost me you know I'm saying so
shot the pics of it too it predicts the
next move
so it plays itself and that's what this
thing with the frame with the frame rate
right they'll run the game from the
server at a super high frame rate so
wait so it'll appear as if it's one to
one on on the gamer side right there
they're trying to sell this thing to you
so bad yes nobody job is on a line I
think it's full bogus these are the
tricks you have to do to get this stuff
to work right I don't I don't know what
X cloud is doing per se but doing that I
can tell you that they don't have the
Miss Cleo in the box
[Laughter]
yes predicting and adapting and you know
I play projects from morning when they
had it in beta it was impressive it was
not one to what I predict that nobody on
the panel purchases it I predict that
nobody will know how it predicts because
nobody gonna be playing the brass say I
really have negative latency in real
life with my mom listen we shall see the
jury's out there we shall see or was
good but that's what I got it was okay
it was it was hot out here these are
streaming streets okay let's get these
this new aisle people and wrap this up
man with the recent announcement and
details of the playstation 5 hardware do
you big project Scarlett can afford to
have less power or equal to the
PlayStation 5 in regards to performance
the choices are a know if PlayStation 5
is more powerful that is the deathblow
4x
be yes quality titles from Xbox game
studios sir plants the power narrative
or see I don't care
stadium negative latency will surpass
all console gaming that is the choices
Rockpile people I would go to make fun
and agenda on some way we all need local
hall window more we got negative latency
maybe that's what we're doing right here
than what you got Rock the Vote please
support you know I'm seeing the lords
out here in the realm Lord addict what
do you have going on man what is what
can people find you know one day I going
on is trying to get this rave done or
I'll definitely be playing leaks
awakening some more today yes I
definitely appreciate everyone coming by
you know we had a great turnout today I
definitely hit that like but we got
nodding on people somebody that like
wanna make it a hundred definitely see
you next week and so next time shout out
to one bad mother-- software get that
one south to one bad mother-- with the
five dollar super chat appreciate how
IOP leads by example disagreements and
discourse with respect in the end gamers
need to back the gamers first you might
be onto something very well some word
that's Larry what it's about we could
disagree but at the same time I so love
it's all respect we go at each other all
the time
that's just what it and you could see us
twenty years ago when we were doing this
in a room like that you let your
immature whatever they were acting
fights they're broken honest
what they said knew about that mom Lord
sovereign man shout out to everybody
can't do their seriously like yeah very
fun chat you guys make the stole it oh
if said we hit 100 no doubt it's it's at
101 I asked for a hundred so I'll go
ahead and unlike the two down boats we
love you to do what it is like it is all
crap in slo-mo I know exactly who wanted
to me good shout out to you brother find
me on Twitter Louis laughs I owe P and B
X sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live and
definitely go check out everything I'll
order gaming dotnet and check out the
latest roundtable reviewing we break
down what we thought about Joker whoa
leave I gotta go see their film a little
bit of the review you like you know me
and Cox out there with the intro and
stuff like that amusing and stuff um you
know I love I love it I look what he's a
couple of things that I put in the chat
I'm tell you what to do next
um but other than that I do love it
trust man we appreciate everybody you
know go watch the video if you can see
Joker um I don't know if there's any
spoilers if you saw the movie Joker then
look at it but then listen
talk to us inside the chat because we
definitely interact with you know
everybody yeah man so salute to that
Lord King man can't West all what else
is going on we could have found people
find you oh man listen check this out
this fine statuary you really have to go
looking I'm not just talking about it
just to talk about
how much you got see her like the other
one woman I have it she's nice she's a
little thin body this is the robust
woman this is a Wonder Woman all right
this is what it do right here a dynamic
pose is beautiful it lights up I would I
did the light off thing and showed
yourself I was not going to watch it at
the site you can see it I have something
very special coming and it's supposed to
be here on Tuesday
that's ask you I've waited for for at
least eight to nine months and it's
already [ __ ] and it's on his way and I'm
gonna probably be one of the first a
beauty and show it to you remember what
I tell you guys I love strength and this
character is the epitome of strength
over the moon fourteen hundred dollars
with shipping um these that this ain't
no joke these are not these stuff that
you go at Gamestop no [ __ ] no no shade
the game stuff that's going out of
business but there's no shade that
there's a little PVC stuff this is real
resin stuff yeah no PVC is plastic vinyl
something look further further all right
I'm also we got combat talk coming up um
all you guys I really need y'all to
first first and foremost if your destiny
had there's no reason why you're now
looking and listening to the last word
that's dad trust me that's why I get all
my destiny information from you want to
know how to do stuff you want to know
ratios what guns is good what's what's
the best build stuff like that
Evon tests and Cognito breaks it down
like no other what's come before you
said damn it cake cake stop when they go
over the services I'm pretty sure you
better serve the city I still get my
cabin oh you had the game with it that's
my dude oh listen and also go to loads
of game in that net when you go to game
there's a tab that's at the top right
and you go to iron Lord you click that
iron laws tab and is subtext and sub to
UM categories that's in it that you can
see all the stuff that we do and all the
stuff that we're about there's a
full-fledged website where you can see
Lord addicts hard game reviews this guy
is not a joke it is not a game with this
dude he really goes into these games
that we and I won't play I won't play it
I'm admiring him for planet thank you
sir and um the won't put up the new
review that's up right now that I was
just getting ready to read could you hit
me this mom man we got a couple man
there's so much we got some new writers
in the building I wanna shout out Lord
Marke oh we got Lord Jean we got a
backspin jump off going on we had this
we had the bank yeah we have the Marvel
joint yeah we had a lot you know say we
got some new writers in the build out
the gene 37 you know I'm saying he's out
there are packs brethren new member
Lords of gaming dotnet and of course
Lord Marko our brother from Romania you
know I'm saying
he put up that Max Payne joint got a lot
of positive feedback man support the
writer we see y'all out there please
retweet you know I'm saying we seeing
I'm here he's here he's come in you know
what deck so we seen you know the growth
there and like I said shout out the
dizzy shout out the Lord Josh raining of
coal old-school-style is moving out here
with the sect stuff but good tu k know
let your finish
you know I'm well I'm done I'm just want
to say shout-out to my block brother
runaway dragon TV if you're not
subscribed or one a dragon TV they're
missing out on stuff right there make
sure you go to his channel subscribe
follow also I'm gonna give a shout out
to Puerto Rock uh you know a lot of
times you know people really give
negative words to people he has never
been ruled to me he has never been
disrespectful to me he has always come
with his facts and I respect the brother
for doing exactly and living his passion
so I and for him to show up inside the
chat and shout out to you brother that's
hella respect the other day I think
somebody put in a super chat like we're
like perfectly which is like look we all
have different viewpoints you know I'm
saying at the end of day we are not
gonna be even the laws we fight amongst
ourselves all the time and it's just
that respect level to be able to come in
here and even like us even I see
you know Russian TV show these little
shots everybody know little shot but at
the end of the day we keep it respectful
we feel how we feel but it's all lovely
watch I ought to feel comfortable in the
realm of the Lord's that's how we rock
like you are soft said we already got
that round table review if you have seen
Joker it's a spoiler cast it is Fire
Lord messes up in the building it was
late you know I'm saying we're gonna be
doing more that please give us your
feedback on now you know the reviews
Lords of game without net we also moving
out here in these streets check that out
the audio all that good stuff will go up
football is rocking and rolling y'all
that's all I got out of you got anything
else before we rock out of here go
Yankees everybody enjoy yes Sunday we
out peace